Welcome to Knowledge Graphs,
moving beyond archeo- RDF.
My name is Kurt Cagle,
and I wanna thank
you for joining
us this afternoon.
A bit of a timeline,
and note that these dates are
only approximate.
RDF, the resource
description framework,
was created in two thousand by
sir Tim Berners
Lee and others,
others, pursuing an idea that
emerged as he was
developing HTML.
With that language,
he'd observed
that hyperlinks,
which connected a phrase or
image in one document
with a document
elsewhere on the web,
could be generalized
to the idea
of one concept or
resource having
a relationship with another
concept in
a conceptual space.
This web of ideas,
which you would
christen the Semantic
Web shortly thereafter,
would end up driving the graph
revolution of
the twenty ten CVR.
Originally, he used
XML as the default
language for this
web, But over time,
he realized that XML wasn't
ideal for the task,
even as he and
others worked at
the logical formalism language
called the Web
Ontology Language
Language or OWL.
By two thousand
seven, SPARQL,
an RDF query language,
was produced to
to querying sets
of assertions using
a new language
called the Chirce
RDF language,
which hurdle,
formally released
in two thousand fourteen.
Sparkle one point
one was released
about the same time,
and it's worth understanding
that Turtle and Sparkle have
only just gotten started.
This is very important as it
effectively marked the end of
the RKO RDF era.
Turtle tends to get a lot of
short shrift first
from ontologists
who grew up with
OWL, RDF XML,
and three notation
and protege.
And from those newer graph
technologies who felt RDF XML
and OWL were too
complex or too
dissimilar from the way that
they were normally
working with
languages like
JavaScript and Python.
However, turtle
as a language,
has a great deal
to recommend it.
It is a much tercer language
than RDF XML. Certainly,
it's that's tercer
than, m three.
And arguably,
it's JSON when namespaces are
taken into account.
Please see JSON LD.
While OWL was built on XML,
RDF XML can be
very verbose and
far from intuitive.
Turtle is actually
a surprisingly
good language for
expressing triples.
It makes a good language
additionally for
prototyping or
modeling objects.
What's more, Turtle and SPARQL
are largely
complimentary because
they essentially
emerged in tandem.
As Sparkle continues
to evolve,
so too does the expressiveness
of Turtle. Indeed,
I contend that
part of the reason
the turtle isn't
used more widely
is because it is a very
young language,
younger than JSON,
and developed to
express a very
different need.
Indeed,
the primary limitations
of Turtle as a language
are simple.
Turtle isn't JSON.
We'll come back to this.
It's worth dividing
up the evolution
of RDF into three
distinct areas
or eras. The first,
the Archaeo RDF
era was largely
dominated by OWL,
utilized n three
for ingestion,
a not very common format,
and was built primarily
for inferencing,
a glorified word
that means that
it is possible to express new
assertions by using logical
operations on
the existing graph
or triples, then adding these
back in as virtual triples.
Serialization was primarily
accomplished via
fairly ugly XML
representation. It appealed to
academics, but was not very
attractive to the woke up
programmers out there.
The Meso RDF era,
on the other hand,
began with SPARQL
one point o,
released in two
thousand and seven,
but took both the emergence of
Turtle around
twenty twelve and
the beefing up of SPARQL in
twenty thirteen to
really take off.
This was RDF's
nuclear winter,
where interest in the semantic
web as an idea
almost died even
as significant new
developments,
the emergence of
turtles, not mammals,
were taking place.
SPARQL one point one brought
with it some
significantly needed
improvements that
was still not
quite sufficient.
The SPARQL update facility was
also introduced,
replacing virtualized triples
with formerly
persistent ones,
and the notion that you could
query in a federated
manner was
introduced, although, again,
not fully fleshed
out at around
the same time. Finally,
we began to see
the first upticks
in the use of JSON
as representations
of troubles, especially in
corporate environments
with JSON
LD linked data.
It could be argued
that JSON LD
is possibly,
probably, in fact,
an evolutionary dead end,
but it is signal signaled that
the two communities
were talking
with one another.
I believe we are
in the beginning
of the NeoRDF era.
There are a whole host of new
developments that
last few years
are beginning to coalesce,
and that will likely
be formalized
within the next
couple of years.
This is not necessarily all
where RDF is going,
but it is what is most visible
right now. I wish
to cover each
of these individually.
The RDF role tends
to spit out big,
scary words. One of these is
reification. A reification is
a statement that
describes another
statement. For instance,
let's say that you
have a statement
that specifies
a relationship,
a has route to relationship,
between two
airports in Seattle
and San Francisco
respectively.
This description
describes a route,
and that route
can have multiple
properties such as distance in
which airlines fly
that particular
route. Labeled
property graphs,
otherwise known as our LPGs,
can can describe the first
relationship but
sputters on the second.
With RDF star, first proposed
in twenty seventeen,
and Sparkle Star,
a more compact notation for
reification was proposed for
both Turtle and Sparkle.
This new notation
makes a great
number of operations much
easier and goes a long way in
making RDF graphs compatible
with local property graphs.
A second area where
some exciting
development is happening is in
the increasing sophistication
of property path languages,
something familiar to users of
both OpenCypher and Gremlin.
With new ways of describing
property graphs as first class
objects and providing ways of
specifying wildcards
and variable
bounds. Such a language could
radically empower SPARQL to
combine both inferencing and
graph analytics
operations into
a single unified language.
While there are
several potential
candidates for
such a language,
Shackle property paths look to
be the most promising
areas yet.
This will be covered more when
I talk about Shackle.
Shackle, the shape
constraint language,
like most RDF technologies,
was formulated in reaction to
the emergence of
turtle as the new
face of RDF.
Going through
several iterations,
it was finally
approved in twenty
seventeen. Shackle,
ironically,
is changing the dialogue about
data modeling with RD web RDF
away from the OWL
specific sets
of rules and
formalisms towards
a format that is more familiar
to data modelers,
application developers,
and data scientists.
In many respects,
it is providing key
in the integration
of r d RDF with
GraphQL as well.
There is an active
community now
looking towards a SPARQL two
point o implementation,
building off of the previous
implementation's weaknesses.
Already, there are limitations
pushing these boundaries by
incorporating
more sophisticated
property paths,
establishing functions,
arrays, sets, and dictionaries
as first class objects,
fixing significant
problems with
lists and how they are managed
in SPARQL, utilization of
JavaScript like capabilities
such as math map reduce
type operators,
lambdas or arrow functions,
and template literals,
and utilizing shackle to make
JSON construction
much easier.
GraphQL is a good idea.
While it is not part of the W
three C stack that
was originally
developed by Facebook,
It should be because it works
very well with what RDF was
intended to be. GraphQL
has limitations.
Reification is
almost impossible
to manage. The JSON data model
is just not as
robust at handling
things RDF does well,
including inheritance.
And its hierarchical structure
is at odds with the potential
secret nature of graphs.
But it is useful language for
making RDF stores
look like JSON
stores from
the outside world.
Shackle is playing
a big part of that,
and almost every
GraphQL bridge
currently in production uses
Shackle on the back end.
With some changes
to sparkle to
make JSON,
constructible directly
from graphs,
this could mark
the merger point
of these two query language
technologies. Region.
The twenty
thirteen specification
is a good start,
but as implementations
have been built,
holes have become obvious.
This will happen soon,
probably within
the next two years.
Finally, it's
worth recognizing
that machine
learning and graph
technologies are in
a collision course,
and it is likely the next
innovations will
be the integration
of these two, for everything
from discoverability to better
classifiers and more robust
machine learning models.
Thank you for listening.
Please feel free to
drop me an email
or contact me on
LinkedIn if you
have any questions.
Thank you.